[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live ein Jahr zeitenwände dazu hat der
Bundeskanzler heute eine
Regierungserklärung abgegeben zu
russlandskrieg in der Ukraine und den
Folgen für uns Deutschland sei im Licht
der zeitenwände widerstandsfähiger
geworden hat er gesagt dass er damit
meint unter anderem das Sondervermögen
das sogenannte Sondervermögen 100
Milliarden Euro zur Stärkung der
Bundeswehr dass er eingerichtet hat
kritik kam prompt von der Opposition von
diesem Sondervermögen sein erst 600
Millionen ausgegeben worden der Vorwurf
von CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz Deutschland
ist immer noch zu langsam der
Bundeskanzler trifft Entscheidungen
nicht schnell genug meint er wir stehen
mir wirklich da in Deutschland sind wir
widerstandsfähiger geworden durch die
Krisen der letzten Jahre und da war das
ja nicht nur die Auswirkungen des Kriegs
in der Ukraine sondern es gab ja auch
noch eine Pandemie vor drei Jahren die
begonnen hat und immer noch nicht vorbei
ist und auch noch viele weitere Krisen
auf dem Weg deshalb wollen wir hier
heute bei uns die Frage stellen sind wir
vorbereitet oder ungeschützt in einem
Krisenfall das ist heute unser Thema und
wir sprechen in dieser Sendung mit einem
krisen- und katastrophenforscher wie wir
da stehen darüber wie wir da stehen hier
in Deutschland und mit einer Expertin
für internationale Sicherheitspolitik
die uns erklärt was wir vielleicht auch
von anderen Ländern lernen können was
die anders machen Dänemark zum Beispiel
hat diese Woche beschlossen einen
Feiertag abzuschaffen um die gewonnenen
Einnahmen in den Wehretat zu stecken und
wir haben vorher im Community Tab euch
gefragt vor dieser Sendung ein Feiertag
für die Finanzierung des Militärs
abschaffen wie findet ihr das und es gab
einige Meinung dazu welche julia schrieb
damit bin ich nicht einverstanden und so
ähnlich Klang dazu wirklich die meisten
Antworten lorenzour schrieb genau ein
super Vorschlag es verschenken wir
unsere Restbestände der Bundeswehr die
Bundeswehr bekommt ein sonder Vermögen
zum Aufbau da gibt man doch gerne einen
Feiertag hey ihr könnt jetzt auch in
dieser Sendung Fragen stellen wir können
zusammen diskutieren wie wir da stehen
hier in Deutschland schreibt die per
Mail einfach oder direkt in den Stream
und zuerst kommen wir jetzt sprechen mit
Prof dr Martin Voss er ist Krisen und
katastrophenforscher von der Freien
Universität Berlin hallo schönen guten
Abend Herr Voss
Herr Dr Voss was würden Sie sagen sind
wir wirklich wiederstandsfähiger
geworden wie der Bundeskanzler das nennt
und wird dann jetzt auch besser
vorbereitet wie sehen Sie das
naja der Anfang von widerstandsfähiger
werden würde ich mal sagen liegt in den
Köpfen heißt wenn wir überhaupt erst mal
anfangen darüber nachzudenken dass wir
eventuell nicht widerstandsfähig genug
waren dann ist der erste wichtige
Schritt immerhin getan sonst sehe ich
noch nicht so sonderlich viel man hat
eben Geld in die Hand genommen und
reagiert sagen wir mal eher so wie man
es üblicherweise gerne tut man kauft
irgendwie Material dazu und damit
vermeintliche Lücken zu füllen lenkt
aber damit die Aufmerksamkeit ja auch
schon gleich wieder in tradierte Pfade
ohne an den tatsächlichen strukturellen
Punkten anzusetzen über die man
vielleicht viel mehr nachdenken sollte
also ich glaube bis jetzt hat sich da
noch nicht wirklich viel bewegt es ist
überhaupt auch nur erstmal ein Beschluss
die Umsetzung folgt ja auch was das
Sondervermögen angeht und weitesten
Sinne noch mal schauen wie schnell
eigentlich die Inflation in größeren
darf Teil davon schon auffrisst aber der
große Schritt ist damit natürlich nicht
getan
und skizzieren wir vielleicht mal die
unterschiedlichen Krisen also derer da
ja wirklich viele in den letzten drei
Jahren eben nicht nur der Krieg in der
Ukraine und die Auswirkungen sondern
also wenn wir auf die letzten drei Jahre
schauen gab es diverse Krisen wo
Deutschland an mehreren Punkten dann
doch sehr unvorbereitet gewirkt hat also
erst die Pandemie und dann eben auch
Situationen wie Naturgefahren die es gab
die schreckliche Auswirkungen hatten im
Aathal NRW da kam auch der Vorwurf wir
waren nicht genug vorbereitet nicht
schnell genug und jetzt eben durch die
militärische Situation in der Ukraine
auch die Energiekrise über die wir lange
gesprochen hatten auf die wir auch
zunächst mal wenig vorbereitet Schienen
also irgendwie wirken wir in allen
Bereichen schlecht vorbereitet scheint
es für Sie uns doch bitte einmal
vielleicht dadurch also auch sind ja
sehr unterschiedliche Krisen warum
stehen wir da so schlecht da
ich glaube man muss tatsächlich
historisch ansetzen erst einmal sehen
dass wir 70 Jahre 75 Jahre Frieden
hinter uns haben in dieser Zeit ist viel
passiert da entwickeln sich
Gesellschaften da sind zwei vielleicht
schon drei Generationen die eigentlich
nur noch wirklich den Frieden als die
Normalität empfinden in der Zeit bildet
sich eine Art von Kultur eine
Einstellung dazu ein
Sicherheitsempfinden kann sich
entwickeln da kann eigentlich nichts
mehr passieren wir können uns auf
unseren Wohlstand konzentrieren das wird
immer nur alles ein bisschen besser hier
oder da haben wir es mit sozialen und
schräg also Ungleichheiten zu tun mit
Schwächen die wir nach und nach noch
angehen müssen aber insgesamt geht's
doch eigentlich nur bergauf dass das
schon nicht die wirkliche Wahrheit war
seit eingestellt natürlich gab es immer
im großen Teil
einer Bevölkerung die schon als solche
auch diese Zeiten als krisenhaft
empfunden haben aber das wo war doch in
diese Richtung sagen wir mal gedacht
ich denke für den Hintergrund müssen
sehen was jetzt passiert ist eine
Pandemie wir gehen aber vielleicht noch
ein Stück weiter zurück da war nein
eleven der war dann im Elbe Hochwasser
im Jahr 2002 hier in Deutschland
wir haben dann jetzt die
flüchtlingskrise gehabt in 2 Jahr
2015/16 wir hatten jetzt die die das
Hochwasser im Juli 2021
stotter schon dadurch und überhaupt nur
die größten Ereignisse als solche zu
benennen und das ist auch noch einen
rechten nationalerblick global müssen
wir noch ganz andere Sachen vielleicht
mit in Betracht ziehen das alles hat
glaube ich schon etwas durchaus damit zu
tun mit diesen Abstand zum Zweiten
Weltkrieg damit haben wir uns in einen
Art Sicherheitsempfinden hinein
entwickelt und haben entsprechend
Institutionen darauf ausgerichtet dass
sie sich um wohlstandsmehrung kümmern
aber wenig eben darum abzusichern dass
mit diesem Wohlstandsgewinn immer auch
andere Arten von Risiken einhergehen
dass wir fortlaufend über die Jahrzehnte
Kosten externalisiert haben ökologische
Kosten die sich irgendwann eben
bemerkbar machen die uns jetzt einholen
über den Klimawandel etwa über
beautiversitätsverlust also diese
gesamte mengenlage muss man sehen und
dann erscheinen die Ereignisse mit denen
wir es jetzt zu tun hatten in den
letzten Jahren leider muss ich
befürchten nicht mehr als
Überraschungsmomente sondern eher als
der Einstieg eben tatsächlich in eine
neue Zeit in der wir konfrontiert werden
eben mit den Folgen unseres eigenen
Handelns gehen wir mal ganz konkret auf
diese Auswirkungen ein unserer User der
uns gerade zusieht Robert Richard
schreibt bis jetzt ist die Faktor nichts
passiert die Lieferketten sind weiterhin
eine Katastrophe wir erinnern uns also
durch Corona die Welt waren weltweite
Pandemie stand ja schon alles
es kam zu Hamsterkäufen die Leute hatten
Angst dass sie das nicht mehr genug gibt
wir erklären Sie sich das haben wir
wirklich so wenig Vorräte in Deutschland
wir haben ja dann auch gelernt
zwischenzeitlich nein es sind eigentlich
genug Vorräte da es dauert nur bis die
in die Regale wandern aber wie stehen
wir da also wenn es jetzt genau auf so
eine Vorbereitung ankommt wie stehen wir
da wenn jetzt Robert Richard schreibt
die die verketten sind weiterhin eine
Katastrophe ist das so
er hat sich ganz bestimmt nicht viel
geändert nein natürlich überblicke ich
auch nicht alles was im kleinen läuft
was
muss man immer viele Leute dazu befragen
wo hier oder da im doch ein paar
Schrauben gedreht worden aber im Großen
und Ganzen sich überhaupt gar keinen gar
keine Veränderung zumal ich eben eine
Veränderung der Mentalitäten dahinter
die Lieferketten sind nach wie vor
vollkommen generabel wir haben nicht
irgendwie strukturiert in den Blick
genommen wo eigentlich die
Schwachstellen in den Lieferketten sind
wie auch gezielt mit
wirtschaftspolitischen Maßnahmen
entsprechend ähm
resilienzen sagen wir mal also Puffer
oder Reserven alternative Strategien
aufgebaut worden wären dazu braucht es
eben ein konzertierten Ansatz man muss
es überhaupt erstmal systematisch
analysieren dann entsprechende Lösungen
entwickeln und implementieren ich denke
mal so weit die mediale Aufmerksamkeit
von dieser Frage schon wieder abgerückt
ist so ist es auch von der politischen
Agenda
er wieder verschwunden die vor zwei
Jahren noch sagten oder müssen aber
unbedingt dran
wir haben noch mehr Kommentare bei
Facebook schreibt Henning Fischer ich
mache vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer ist
ein langer Kommentar mit mehr als einer
fundamentalen Krise kommen wir nicht
klar schreibt er meint meint er nennt
hier eine grundkrise und zwischen das
Klima und alle weiteren Krisen sein
deshalb nur unter enorm Belastung und
Verlusten zu bewältigen und da wir eben
es nicht schaffen würden die Klimakrise
effektiv einzudämmen befürchtet er dass
ich in den nächsten 30 Jahren nichts
ändern wird sehen Sie das genauso düster
von der Prognose her
solange das mindset ich sag's noch
einmal es liegt in den Köpfen nicht
grundlegend verändert die diese
Grundhaltung dass man die Prozesse
eigentlich sich selbst überlassen kann
ja der Markt reguliert ist wir haben
institutionell von Behörden
administrativer Seite schlicht keine
Kapazitäten und Kompetenzen mehr
entwickelt um nicht gut laufende
Prozesse zu korrigieren intervenieren zu
können wir haben im Grunde genommen alle
unsere Kompetenzen die es durchaus sind
viele da Hinsicht mal gehabt abgebaut
brauchen wir alles nicht mehr das läuft
ja schon irgendwie so deshalb der
Einstieg der 100 Milliarden in die Hand
zu nehmen um dann irgendwo Material oder
Ausrüstung für die Bundeswehr sind
zuzukaufen
spricht für mich eben überhaupt nicht
für eine Zeitenwende zeitenwände würde
für mich implizieren dass man sagt wir
müssen an die institutionellen
Grundlagen heran wir müssen darüber
nachdenken mal Prozesse eigentlich bei
und so wie sie geregelt sind gut
geregelt sind ob dahinter eigentlich
entsprechende personelle Kompetenzen
stehen auf allen Ebenen die geeignet
sind im nicht nur das Tagesgeschäft zu
bewältigen sondern sogar noch
vorausschauend in die Zukunft zu gucken
was könnte denn dort wohl auf eine
Kommune auf ein Landkreis oder ein
Bundesland wie auch immer insgesamt auf
einen zukommen also dieses strategisch
vorausschauende Momentum sehe ich
nirgends und das würde ich doch eben
erwarten wenn man wirklich von der
Zeitenwende spricht dass man genau auch
dahin den Blick richtet
wie man die Bevölkerung am besten
schützt das ist sie haben es auch schon
angesprochen eben also wirklich ein
Thema über das man sich ja schon sehr
lange Gedanken macht also auch wirklich
schon seit Jahrzehnten und wie
Zivilschutz früher aussah und was davon
heute noch übrig ist ein Beitrag von
Franziska von thiesenhausen gehen wir
zusammen anschauen
bei ABC Alarm und zwingendem Aufenthalt
im Freien
Regenmantel mit glatter Haut und Kapuze
anziehen notfalls Decke oder Plane über
den Kopf und Körper hängen bis in die
80er Jahre war die Angst vor einem
Atomkrieg in Deutschland allgegenwärtig
und die Bevölkerung wurde entsprechend
vorbereitet
rund 2000 öffentliche Bunkeranlagen gab
es während des Kalten Krieges in der
Bundesrepublik sowie diese hier in
Dortmund deren Tauglichkeit 1964 knapp
eine Woche lang von etwa 150 Personen in
einem freiwilligen Experiment getestet
wurde die Bilanz
Unbequemlichkeiten und die schmale
bunkerkost waren von den Gedanken an das
50 Mark Tageshonorar in den Schatten
gestellt worden einmal täglich kam die
Post
gefangen aber jetzt
warst du nach dem Ende des Kalten
Krieges wurden viele Anlagen aufgegeben
oder umfunktioniert knapp 600 Bunker
theoretisch mit Platz für eine halbe
Million Menschen gibt es noch aber
funktionsfähig sind wohl nur die
allerwenigsten
heute informieren sich Politiker zum
Beispiel in Finnland darüber wie eine
moderne Bunker Infrastruktur aussehen
kann dort gibt es im ganzen Land
unterirdische Schutzräume die auch in
Friedenszeiten sinnvoll genutzt werden
Finnland eben schon Thema bei einer
modernen Bunker Infrastruktur Jupiter
Zeus der User bei Facebook ist er oder
sie schreibt was ist nötig um ein
Zivilschutz und Infrastruktur wie in
Finnland zu schaffen ist dies politisch
umsetzbar das glauben sie
keine leicht zu beantwortende Frage
natürlich politisch umsetzbar ökonomisch
finanzierbar von der Gesellschaft
insgesamt eigentlich auch gewollt also
ich würde immer erstmal sagen nein nicht
irgendwie so ohne weiteres natürlich
nicht in Deutschland heute lasen dass
die Bahn auf das Jahr 2017 große Pläne
ausrichtet dann würde ich mal sagen in
dem Zeitraum wäre das vielleicht auch
realistisch den Zivilschutz auf einem
finnischen Stand zu bringen in
Deutschland
ich glaube also nein ja
und neben jetzt Bunkern gibt es ja
natürlich noch viel weiteres was also
nee diesen Zivilschutz bedeutet was ist
meint also wenn wir jetzt auch gerade
nämlich in Zukunft schauen müssen wir ja
auch an cybersicherheit zum Beispiel
denken nur ein Stichwort wie stehen wir
denn da da ihrer Meinung nach wie
sieht's aus
auch dort lerne ich natürlich primär von
Leuten die sich mit cybersicherheit
beschäftigen da bin ich nicht der
ITER der das von innen her beurteilen
kann ich sehe aber natürlich auch dort
wieder als Sozialwissenschaftler dahin
wie haben wir uns eigentlich in diese
Verletzlichkeiten gegenüber
Cyberangriffen hinein entwickelt auch
dort sehe ich eine gewisse
nein keine gewisse eine sehr große muss
ich eigentlich sagen Naivität man lässt
sich eben auf solche Prozesse schlicht
ein und setzt da drauf dass die Lösung
schon auch irgendwie mitkommen wird also
man entwickelt Technologie man
entwickelt eine Abhängigkeit von
kritischen Infrastrukturen wie etwa eben
der digitalen
Kommunikationsinfrastruktur eine gleiche
Maßen bei der Entwicklung auch mit zu
bedenken welche Schwachstellen das denn
impliziert und wie ist ein anfällig
macht das soll dann irgendwie später
kommen sondern da haben wir uns im
Grunde genommen
[Musik]
jetzt stellt sich natürlich aber auch
die Frage was muss was soll was was kann
der Staat leisten und wo habe ich aber
vielleicht auch eine hohe Schuld
natürlich als Bürgerin als Bürger was
muss ich vielleicht selbst machen was
wäre da ihre Einschätzung also wie
können wir einzelne vielleicht besser
werden aber eben auch der Staat
resilienter in Krisen besser im Umgang
mit Krisen
ich sag mal so die tradierte halt
Antwort wäre darauf kaufen sie sich
Wasser und ein paar Vorräte für die
nächsten Tage
lernen Sie ein bisschen was über den
Selbstschutz und wie man sich in selbst
entsprechend auch noch versorgen kann
wenn der Strom mal ausfällt und so
weiter das ist im Grunde genommen die
100 Milliarden kauf dir was die Lösungen
so trivial funktioniert leider nicht in
komplexen Krisenlagen und
gravierenden Katastrophen
auch dort muss man eigentlich sagen wir
managen diese Krisen und Katastrophen in
ihrer Komplexität und ihrer Dynamik
ihrem übereinander lagern von ganz
unterschiedlichen Prozessen nicht durch
ein paar Vorräte sondern durch eine
Haltung wiederum durch ein Bewusstsein
darüber dass man sich damit
auseinandersetzen muss was kann
eigentlich passieren das wird übrigens
keine Panik in der Bevölkerung wenn man
darüber offen spricht was so alles
möglich ist kein Mensch auf der läuft
deshalb Amok von Hamster kaufen
versprechen dann sind das in der Regel
Sachen die jeder Supermarkt nach zwei
Wochen mindestens ein paar Tagen wieder
kompensiert hat wenn dann mal zu viel
Klopapier gekauft ist ist das sozusagen
unsere Panik in Deutschland auf dem
Niveau würde ich mal sagen ist immer
alles im grünen Bereich also man kann
mit der Bevölkerung sehr offen darüber
man muss mit ihr sehr offen darüber
sprechen damit sie dann die Möglichkeit
hat auch sich ein Bild zu machen und zu
sagen das sind das erwarten wir von dem
Staat an Leistungen es Support auf der
anderen Seite kann dann aber auch von
Behörden und staatlicher Seite eben
gesagt werden ja und das sind das sind
die Aufgaben die du Bürger oder
BürgerInnen im übernehmen musst wir
sitzen alle in einem Boot gemeinsam wir
schaffen komplexe krisenkatastrophen
eben nur wenn man gemeinsam alle auch
mit anpacken da hat jeder seine Rolle
also nach einem Ereignis zu sagen der
oder die Landrätin war schuld ist
wiederum nur ein ganz typisches ähm ja
äh Sündenbock suchen was überhaupt nicht
zur Problemlösung beiträgt das müsste
sich
bei jedem eigenes eigentlich jeder und
jeder an den selbst an den Kopf fassen
und überlegen irgendwas hätte ich wohl
getan hätte ich mich korrekt verhalten
was könnte ich tun damit ich zukünftig
dass wir meinen kann also es ist eine
Art Bewusstseinsbildungsprozess den wir
angehen sollten keine Panik und ein
neues Bewusstsein sagt Professor Dr
Martin Voss vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns
zu Gast waren
es gibt ein paar Menschen die sich aber
besser fühlen wenn sie sich akribisch
auf mögliche Krisen vorbereiten im ganz
hoch professionellen Stil läuft das
teilweise ab man nennt sie dann prepper
was das genau bedeutet und welche
Vorbereitungen von Behörden auch
gleichzeitig aber ganz offiziell
empfohlen werden ein Beitrag von Josua
schwarz
sie sind vorbereitet tagelange
Stromausfälle Unterbrechung der
Grundwasserversorgung oder andere Krisen
prepper wie Philip Jakubowski sind für
solche Szenarien bestens ausgestattet
grundsätzlich ist das auch nicht viel
Arbeit bei jedem Einkauf ein bisschen
was extra mitnehmen eine extra Dose
Ravioli im Kasten Wasser extra einpacken
den beiseite stellen wenn man das über
4-5 Wochen macht dann hat man seinen
Notvorrat fertig
werden von vielen belächelt doch das
preppen ist spätestens seit Putins
Einmarsch in die Ukraine stärker in den
Fokus gerückt auch hier in Düsseldorf
bereiten sie sich in einem
Selbsthilfekurs auf mögliche Krisen vor
hier lernen Sie unter anderem was ist
für unterschiedliche Sirenen laute gibt
aber auch welche Lebensmittel sie zu
Hause lagern sollten
das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe empfiehlt einen
10-tages-vorrat mit 20 Liter Wasser 3,5
Kilogramm Getreideprodukte 4 Kilogramm
Gemüse und Hülsenfrüchte
2,5 Kilogramm Obst und Nüsse
2,6 kg Milch und Milchprodukte 1,5 kg
Fisch Fleisch und Eier und 0,357 kg
Fette und Öle dazu kommen noch eine
gefüllte Hausapotheke Campingkocher und
ein batteriebetriebenes Radio um ein
Informationen zu kommen
sollten wir also alle unsere
Vorratsschränke füllen
bei uns jetzt Serafine Dinkel von der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik sie weiß vor allem auch was
andere Länder besser machen schön dass
Sie bei uns sind hallo Frauke schönen
guten Abend Frau Dinkel wäre mir gerade
gesehen also so vorbereitet wie eben im
Beitrag das ist teilweise natürlich sehr
sehr gut vorbereitet dann das ist im
Ausland oftmals mehr verbreitet hier in
Deutschland lächelt man ja eher über
warum ist das so warum ist das bei uns
tatsächlich eher sowas worüber man
lächelt und im Ausland ist es teilweise
ganz normal
ich glaube das ist was was Herr
Professor Voss vorher schon ein bisschen
angesprochen hat dass dieses
individuelle Risiko bewusst sein bei uns
über die letzten Jahrzehnte Frieden eben
nicht so stark ausgeprägt ist wie in
anderen Ländern wenn wir zum Beispiel in
den hohen Norden schauen nach Finnland
oder nach Schweden
haben wir eine ganz andere
gefahrenperfektion also Finnland z.B das
ja nicht 1300 km lange Landgrenze mit
Russland teilt und auch aktuell ja nicht
Mitglied in einer verteidigungsallianz
ist
und daher man sich andere Wege überlegt
hat möglichst widerstandsfähig gegenüber
einer möglichen Bedrohung von außen zu
sein also in manchen Staaten hat das
irgendwie Jahrzehnte lange Tradition
einerseits ein Verständnis für
möglicherweise riesen
Gefahren Naturkatastrophen zu bilden auf
der anderen Seite
jedes auch um
individuelle Verantwortung und das
Gefühl
einer gesellschaftlichen Kohäsion
in der alle Individuen eigentlich zum
Funktionieren der Gesamtgesellschaft und
zur gemeinsamen Sicherheit beitragen
wir haben es auch gerade im Beitrag noch
mal gesehen genau die finden die da
schon ewig mein Bunkersystem haben
tatsächlich fast für die gesamte
Bevölkerung also auch ganz spannend
Estland fällt auch immer wieder als ein
Beispiel aus dem Ausland von dem man
lernen kann werden es auch schon ganz
kurz angesprochen vorhin also gerade
beim Thema cybersicherheit was würden
Sie sagen es Estland da auch oder was
was konkret können wir uns vielleicht
bei den nächsten abgucken was ist was
ist da so spannend
wir haben ja vorher darüber gesprochen
dass es eigentlich in den letzten Jahren
sehr viele und sehr unterschiedlich
gestaltete Krisen gab
die Frage ist so ein bisschen welche
Konsequenzen haben wir daraus gezogen
und wir haben angedeutet dass wir
teilweise nicht so viele Konsequenzen
daraus gezogen haben und in Island hat
man eben aus einer massiven selber
Attacke vor über einem Jahrzehnt eben
gelernt und als Reaktion darauf selber
Kapazitäten gebildet
und auch in der informierte Gesellschaft
was solche Themen angeht geschaffen
also ich glaube
Sicherheit konkret kann ich Ihnen jetzt
nicht die einzelnen Maßnahmen aufzählen
aber ich glaube dieses Bewusstsein für
wir sind in bestimmten Bereichen wohl
noch habe aber auch wir tun was dagegen
und wir sind alle dafür
mitverantwortlich dass diese vitalen
Funktionen weiterlaufen
das können wir uns denke ich abgucken
ein User eine Userin schreibt bei uns
bei Youtube macht richtig Mut das
Programm gestern Land zu Atombomben und
heute wird unsicher erzählt dass der
zivilschutzpraktischen praktisch nicht
existiert aber ich glaube darum geht es
nicht es geht ja um das mindset dass man
eben wenn ich das richtig verstehe sie
und auch Herrn Professor Voss das ist
weniger
angstbehaftet sein sollte sich auf
Krisen vorzubereiten was würden Sie
einem User der sich jetzt davon so
niedergedrückt fühlt und ihn das
irgendwie erschlägt hier gerade unser
Programm würden sie das für uns noch mal
einordnen wie das gemeint ist
tatsächlich
ja gerne ich glaube ich habe da
vielleicht auch eine etwas
optimistischere Sicht als Professor Voss
ich würde nämlich durchaus sagen dass
ich in den letzten Jahren
einiges verändert hat auch auf der
politischen Ebene
was die Priorisierung von Resilienz was
Gesetzgebung zum Thema kritische
Infrastrukturen angeht was Versuche
angeht das Information einzudämmen also
ich denke da sieht man auf
unterschiedlichen Ebenen von NATO EU
Bundesebene bis hin zur kommunalen Ebene
dass ich da doch einiges getan hat
allein im letzten Jahr auch dass es auch
zum gewissen Maße eine
Zeitenwende auch in manchen
innenpolitischen Strukturen gegeben hat
also das Bundesminister
Bundesinnenministerium
dass ein neues dachgesetz für den Schutz
von kritischen Infrastrukturen auf dem
Weg bringt auf EU-Ebene dann gibt es
neue Richtlinien zum Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur es läuft sehr viel
Zusammenarbeit zwischen der EU und der
NATO was die Nutzung von
zivilen Infrastrukturen für zum Beispiel
die Bewegung von militärischen Material
angeht und da hat sich in einem relativ
kurzen Zeitrahmen relativ viel getan
und ähnlich wie Professor Voss eingangs
gesagt hat die Tatsache dass wir jetzt
über Resilienz reden ist schon mal gut
das ist nämlich ein Thema das politisch
nicht so arg spannend ist
also mit dem Thema resilien im Wahlkampf
zu gewinnen aber eigentlich auch nur
deswegen weil es um den Erhalt von
Dingen geht die bereits funktionieren
also was macht vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr Mut zu sagen eigentlich leben wir
in einer funktionierenden Gesellschaft
und wir überlegen uns jetzt wie diese
Gesellschaft
zukünftigen und aktuellen ganze
standhaft standhalten kann und wie wir
auch das war auch eine user-frage wie
wir nicht nur reaktiv mit bestimmten
Krisen umgehen können sondern auch die
wir mit langfristigen komplexen
verketteten quasi dauerkrisen oder Dauer
Herausforderungen umgehen können
auf die wir dann nämlich nicht nur
reagieren müssen sondern mit denen wir
einfach lernen müssen umzugehen die wir
absorbieren ähm
lernen müssen also ein Beispiel dafür
ist vielleicht im Umgang mit diesen
Informationen ähm ist reaktives handeln
nur so Mittel sinnvoll also wenn eine
falsche Nachricht erst mal vom Endnutzer
konsumiert wurde ist die super schwer
wieder aus der Welt zu schaffen und da
kann ich dann irgendeine Faktencheck auf
meiner Ministeriums Webseite
veröffentlichen aber das wird
wahrscheinlich die Person nicht
erreichen die die falsche Nachricht und
konsumiert habe hat aber wenn ich
investiere in
Medienkompetenzen wenn ich BürgerInnen
die Kompetenzen
bereitstelle um zu erkennen okay das ist
eine falsche Nachricht die kommt
wahrscheinlich von außen und das glaube
ich jetzt erst gar nicht dann haben wir
eine viel höhere Widerstandsfähigkeit
als wenn wir immer nur von von Gefahr zu
Gefahren von Krise zu Krise Rennen und
müssen wir dann auch finanziell viel
mehr investieren
ja also Prävention kostet Geld aber ich
glaube ein wichtiger Punkt ist auch
Prävention kostet meistens weniger Geld
als die eingetroffene Krise also das ist
oft beim Thema Klimaanpassung Thema
Wie teuer wird es uns zu stehen kommen
wenn wir eben nicht in Anpassungen
Investition investieren ähm da gibt es
bestimmte Forschungen zum Beispiel
nach Hurricanes sind Vereinigten Staaten
wie viel das eigentlich gekostet hat
Krisen zu bewältigen und das ist weniger
gekostet hätte einfach in vernünftige
funktionierende robuste Systeme zu
investieren
ich glaube wieder das Problem ist dass
das
in den politischen System in dem es
kurzfristig ausgerichtete man dafür gibt
eben nicht so leicht zurechtfertigen ist
in Prävention zu Investition zu
investieren
wir sprechen da immer von dem
präventions-
wenn ich in Vorsorge investiere und
dadurch eine Krise vermeide
das kann ich nicht beweisen das kann ich
nicht politisch verkaufen weil die Krise
ist ja nicht passiert
aber eigentlich müssen wir eben hin zu
einem positiven narrativ von wir sind
gerüstet für
für Risiken von morgen und wir möchten
aktiv daran investieren aber wir sind
auch ehrlich und wir kommunizieren dazu
dass
Krisen Kosten haben werden und das
bestimmte
Herausforderungen langfristig auch für
Individuen Kosten haben werden da will
ich deshalb noch mal ein Thema
aufgreifen was wir schon besprochen
haben aber es kommt häufiger in den
Kommentaren jetzt gerade wieder bei
Facebook von anderen Nebel die sagt
einem deprimieren dabei Beitrag müssen
wir jetzt Hamstern und Bunker bauen oder
was will uns das ZDF mit diesem
Livestream rüberbringen noch mal von
ihnen also ein kurzes Schluss Statement
vielleicht worum es hier eigentlich geht
ich habe es jetzt schon häufiger gehört
von ihnen es geht darum dass wir eine
funktionierende Gesellschaft sind die
nur lernen muss auf Krisensituation zu
reagieren aber gerne für Sie dass Sie
das Wort haben auch zum Schluss gerne
noch mal eine Antwort an jetzt diese
sorgenvollen stimmen wir jetzt von einer
Nebel
ja ich glaube angstgetrieben Handeln
nein vorbereitet sein ja müssen wir
Hamsterkäufe tätigen nein müssen wir
nicht aber ich denke es ist ein relativ
niedrigschwellige Möglichkeit sich
vorzubereiten einfach zu gucken dass man
so ein bisschen Wasser im Keller hat und
dann minimalen medikamentenvorrat das
kostet uns als Individuen jetzt nicht so
viel
und gleichzeitig müssen wir uns darüber
jetzt nicht konstante Gedanken machen
was wäre wenn
XYZ Extremfall Eintritt ähm weil wir
gesehen haben dass sehr viele Krisen
schwer vorhersehbar sind und ich glaube
wenn wir verstehen wie verschiedene
Akteure zusammenarbeiten wer für was
beantwortlich ist und ähm Vertrauen und
Korrosion innerhalb einer Gesellschaft
schaffen aufrecht zu erhalten dann
können wir auch langfristigen
Herausforderungen und akuten Krisen
begegnen
Dinkel von der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für auswärtige Politik vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns waren
vielen Dank
und ich hoffe das hat auch euch jetzt
zum Schluss noch mal einen ja ein
bisschen ein positiveren Ausstieg aus
der Sendung gegeben denn das ist so
darum sollte es ja gehen dass wir euch
informieren können in diesen Gesprächen
diesen beiden Expertengesprächen die wir
geführt haben wie wir einfach besser
vorbereitet sein können ich fand es
spannend ich hoffe ihr auch schön dass
ihr dabei wart bis zum nächsten Mal
gerne wieder tschüss